hey everyone it's my father and welcome
to the auto pose market analysis for
Monday September 25 2017 and the
economic news that came out was actually
kind of mixed you know yeah the Dallas
Fed manufacturing report which showed
some strength and basically shows no
effects from Hurricane Harvey the
National Index however did weaken due to
drops in August industrial production
and housing starts gold caught a bit
today was up about 1.2 percent you know
we had a lot of words over the weekend
with North Korea crude oil was also up
crude was how much was that we got above
52 bucks equities yeah we eased off a
little bit settled around just under
2500 Angela Merkel did win but it's kind
of disappointing and you know the the
Euro went went south so we'll see what's
going to happen over the next couple
weeks again brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation a buy or
sell a futures contract or making any
other type of investment decision future
train contentious natural risk and is
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all in more than the
initial investment risk capital as money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be as we're
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
Patrick Lawrence is not necessarily
indicative of future results
okay the tools we used in this
presentation are the same it's the order
flows trader which is the volume
footprint chart the Delta scalper and
the price rejector Delta scalper and
pressure deck there are two additional
tools now you know the oarfish trader
has a few extra benefits that you don't
see in normal footprint charts and one
of them are ratios and order flows
divergence which you know there's a
perfect there's a trade setup that
happens every day almost every day in in
the markets and when it happens it's
quite potent I'm going to show you today
I occurred in the bonds then we get my
bond chart here okay so this is the
bonds bonds we had been in in a pretty
confined range most of the morning we
started breaking out of it around 4:00
started making these new highs but
before that very tight range and you
know right off the high here you
I'm going into the high you have the
Delta surge given a by coming off the
high you got Delta surge given a cell
you know again I'm always looking for
reasons to be selling at a high rather
than necessarily be buying although you
know you got some bullish signs here you
got you know the Delta surge you've got
buying imbalances here does the market
go higher yeah it goes higher but it
only goes higher by about four ticks
then it starts going sideways you
getting some signs in here that the
market is ready for sell off you got
Delta increasing you've got a nice big
selling a balance here you got bearish
ratios and the market does sell off it
sells off down into this low low the day
down here at 8:34 and you got a bunch of
stuff here you've got divergence right
here so you get the positive Delta on
the low next bar you got the ratio even
in the bar where you're at yeah so have
a ratio so you got your divergence in a
ratio next bar you also got a bullish
ratio you know it's one thing to look at
a ratio but you gotta understand what's
bullish wants bearish right I mean other
software they they're starting to add
these ratios in there but you know they
don't necessarily teach you how to use
them you know it's nice that they're
adding them in there I mean cuz it's you
know I like first hour as far as I'm
concerned I'm the guy that was the first
one to put them out there but you know
they're just taking my ideas but they're
not you know they don't know how to use
it they're just putting it in because
people say hey you know I want to look
at a ratio is there but I mean it's kind
of pointless to have the ratio if you
don't you know have the proper
understanding of what to look for but
anyway you know you've got the bullish
ratio the bullish ratio divergence price
rejector here this green line is the
price projector so I know that there's
price rejection coming down in here at
this low as well so that that's you know
for me that's a pretty confident sign
that this market go go higher because
we're seeing price rejection right above
you know the 154 even what does that
mean Christ's rejection oh it means
people are rejecting these prices they
don't want to be selling below you know
154 so they're rejecting prices below I
mean what's gonna happen is the markets
gonna move up and market moves up we go
up from our low 150 402 but that's not
where you'd be buying you'd be mined
somewhere in here on six or seven and
won't rally up to the highs and keep
going up making new highs then you hit
your high level not much happens you
just basically go sideways after that
for the rest of the day but again you
know this is the trade right here again
you know how many points is that you
know and say you're buying it at you
know this this yellow line is the
opening price of the day which is 150
408 so say you're buying it even at o8
you know say you're not buying it
anywhere you know at 7 or 6
I mean you buy it at a 8 you know
rallies all the way up to 20 pretty
pretty quick over the next hour and goes
higher you know so it goes all the way
up above 28 so that's not saying you'd
get 20 ticks out of it but I know some
people that that would but you know
that's the trade that's entrained to
have today you know that that's that's
the trade of the day as they you know
hutch these these guys but um you know
five years very similar so again you
know this is the ratio and divergence
that you talk that I talk about almost
every day you know some days it's not as
pretty as this one but you know this
one's pretty darn nice five years you
didn't have a ratio and divergence
although what you had in the five years
you know five years were moving quite
nicely today and we just find my chart
is but you had this nice signal here
just right around that same time 834 but
what do you got in the five years is the
Delta scalper giving you the buy excuse
me take something drink and you know
this is actually quite nice so earlier
you excuse me earlier this cough um so
earlier divergence and then look you got
the Delta here four thousand ten minus
three thousand minus nine hundred then
plus three thousand so the Delta even
though we're going lower we're going
lower on weakening Delta okay you can
see how it's it's actually the bars is
actually rising and I wants a rising
Delta because it's still negative but
it's getting less weaker and then you
hit three low very strong positive Delta
Delta scalper kicks in telling you hey
you should be you know you're seeing a
shift in here from a supply driven
market a market that's going lower to a
demand driven market and again you know
the watch was
opinion in this market here okay you
have this one vine imbalance okay but
here you got twenty seven hundred
thirteen hundred five thousand eight
hundred three thousand then you're
coming down in here you're not at the
turn yet but you're seeing some mine
coming in 2681 still down still down you
know we still got a little bit of
selling left and boom you hit the low
here 155 Lots trade let's swing low and
then the buying just comes right back up
boom you know two thousand eight
thousand a nice big positive Delta next
bar three thousand but Delta scalper
kicking off here so you should be
looking to be buying somewhere around
the twenty four level and what happens
is boom we just rally rally rally right
all the way up up up up the new highs
you know where we come up in here around
the twenty eight twenty eight and a half
level so from 24 up to twenty eight and
a half
that again is a nice move you know even
earlier yeah you know tight range it's
very similar to the bonds here I started
making your highs around four new highs
then you sold off 8:34 you got your turn
as well as you just had in the bonds you
know that was at eight thirty four so
you know people asked you know is fives
and fives and bonds move the same in
general yes but the signals you're gonna
get are a bit different
alright so before I go and talk about
crude now but before I go into crew
don't show you this crude chart is a
ranges if didn't bar chart this is the
Delta scalper on here I also run bar
charts with the Delta scalper because
sometimes I I've got a lot of charts
open and it's easy for me sometimes to
see these indicators on a normal bar
chart but it's easy for me to explain
sometimes because you know sometimes
I've tried to explain it on a bar chart
on a footprint chart and people get
confused with the numbers but anyway
here this is a nice buy here so this is
around 3:40 in the morning you know
you're getting along somewhere around
fifty double fifty fifty-five and was it
dude rallies rallies all the way up to
the morning around nine o'clock II get
the cell at 51 i what that is 51 30 so
from 50 55 up to 50 130 what is that 80
cent move more or less you get the cell
here it doesn't really work out it just
eventually go sideways and then
starts rallying and then you got a trade
here late in the day that doesn't work
out so you know people will what to do
is you know the turn on machine on and
they'll just look oh you got the scalper
give me a buy here yeah I broke even
I should I give me a sell I broke even
and then I lost on this trade okay well
did you take this trade oh no I didn't
well you know it's one of those things I
mean you know it's like well yeah you
could pick you know periods yeah I can
show you little periods in here of
losing trades but you know there's also
other trades that you're not taking and
you know your career is not built on one
or two trades it's built over a period
of time right it's a it's a marathon
it's not a sprint you know in trading
and thinking that oh you know like here
for example ah I want to show you that
chart just terrible chart to show that's
the wrong chart that's a 233 tick trade
in crude but it's a footprint watch my I
got one that's a bar chart it's a little
easier to read Nasdaq I think I gotta
throw that in up here here it is so it's
like here this is a 233 tick chart okay
so again you know you could say well you
get a lot of trades going on in here
yeah sometimes people will say yeah I
took this trader loss I took this
trainer loss well did you take this
trade yeah but you know I had these two
losers here if you're just gonna take a
snapshot of one or two trades and say
they lost you know I mean look at it
over the course of a trading day you
know how many trades again again you
know 233 tick traders to me is is crazy
for someone to trade but yeah I know
somebody that does I don't know how
successful they are at it for me it's
just just too much I don't want to say
noise was just too much action for me
you know I don't like to be trying to
scalp one or two ticks I prefer to try
and get you know more out of a trade you
know fifty ticks eighty ticks rather
than around in here oh I get
short no no I got a cover I buy now I
get a short you know like that back and
forth you know there's a time and place
for it but again I wouldn't use a 233
tick chart for that
you know but anyway let me just jump
into the crude oil chart here if I could
find the one footprint chart give me a
second okay before I had I couldn't
close it for some reason now I can't
open it but there's some interesting
things here so again you know this
morning
you know 3:40 right off that low here
you don't have a divergence you don't
have you know much of anything there you
do have the Balto's indicator kick it
off giving you a buy there then you know
here's you got your Delta scalper with
your ratio the market just rallied
rallied rallied you can show running up
in here 6:00 in the morning got very
aggressive buying all those bars almost
all aggressive buying and in the form of
buying imbalances and you know you take
out the highs you get up here you got
more imbalances you hit this level up
here 51:39 we start going come off a
little bit start going sideways now this
is interesting in here and this bar here
in this bar here look at this volume
that's on the bottom of the bar this is
what's supportive buying looks like so
even though you got negative Delta why
do you have negative deltas because you
got supportive buying in here you have
very strong vol 3 94 682 810 169 even to
a lesser extent back here 747 680 58 you
know 348 so you know on this side on
this chunk on this bottom I'll say
bottom half but you know bottom 4/9
there's something of that bar 4 / 9
whatever that is you know you're getting
some very strong buying in there even
here you're getting some you know as
people are trying to sell it and
offering it it's getting bought up here
six hundred eight hundred seven hundred
four hundred and it's just very very
nice this is very nice to see and was
the market do it puts a nice a little
rally up in here you know a nice little
rally but you know it's about 10 ticks
you get up here you got Delta scalper
you got a bearish ratio here at 51 43
and again this is I have the Straits up
it's called the o 2x trade and what it
is
you got your bearish ratio look for a
pullback towards that level you know -
well that's the - so you're looking for
a pullback within two ticks of that
level and you get it within one tick of
the high actually so 51:43 your
beginning short at 51 you know you're
throwing an offer when you're training
down here you're throwing an offer at 50
141 which is two ticks off the high so
why is it called the Oh two x's you put
a circle around here that's your Oh
you throw in an offer two ticks off that
high which is in this case is 50 141
that your offer wait for the pullback up
there and then X x marks the spot much
lower you know in this case it's 20
ticks you don't get in short at fifty
one forty one down to 51 20 21 I'm
saying you would have got perfectly
there you know maybe you're getting in
here you're getting out at 15 ticks but
you're just risking three ticks right
you're getting short at 43 I'll show you
have 41 and you're stops just one tick
above the high at 43 44 rather so that's
three ticks
and what are you getting out of it you
know 15 12 15 18 ticks out of it so
you're getting you know more than a
three to one risk reward ratio so that's
the that's the trade that you want to
get again this is the bar chart of the
euro currency
you know the euro currency had a big
move yesterday's in Germany and so I'm
just going back to you know European
open oh it's right here one o'clock so
151 you get a little buy here yeah what
you would've got up and then you got a
nice sell here from I don't know what
this is sixty seven sixty I'll call it
65 you know I'll move all the way down
here to 50 this buy doesn't work but
then you get a nice little sell here I
don't know if I would have stopped you
out right here I'm by here that sort of
doesn't work out and then you sort of
sit quiet for another hour or two then
you start getting some more buys and
sells you know by signal here sell
signal there a little buy here another
sell here this buy fails then you get a
cell signal here on the twenty area and
the confirm backed up with another cell
signal five ticks lower so from you know
one nineteen twenty all the way down
below one 1900 before
handing out the day around just a little
bit higher but again you know I don't
know what you would have got out of this
could have got at least 20 ticks out of
the 24 ticks in the euro currency is is
this is nice okay so thanks for watching
this presentation to learn more about
trading software using this presentation
and how you can profit from wonderful
visit my website overflows calm oh and
fun learn more about scalping go to
Delta scalper calm or you can be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel to get
more information I try to post videos up
everyday or there abouts I do have a
couple presentations I'm working on one
is about trading soybeans I said I've
been getting a lot of questions and I've
been putting together another
presentation on just general questions
and answers I get about order flow so
look for those in the next few days so
thanks everyone have a great day bye bye